great story you know the last robbery I
was telling you about before the store
we were casing other stores and I went
into a store but the lady took my plate
number down she wanted to sell me a ring
she wanted to get you know come back
because I was looking at nice expensive
Rings that's how your case stores so she
just happens to have my plate number I
don't know this of course at the time
look at your face that's what he's
saying
let me tell you the FBI flooded the area
they [__] checked every jewelry store
in the area and went in it was anybody
try to ask these questions before the
case in it they went in they They
confiscated every camera in one of my
convictions I am seen in a a Wawa store
next to the jewelry store the day of or
the day before then they got me and then
they ended up convicting me on four
stores they closed 21 22 cases it was
opposite of 18 million all from just
that
[__] that's how you get taken down
because ladies don't really wants to do
her job well exactly oh [__]